there was an amazing fight card did you
guys see this I did not see it
UFC 249 it was one of the best fight
cards I've ever seen by fight card I
mean like all the fights that were on it
yeah it was one of the best fight cards
I've ever seen I've this time like a
long time boxing fan yeah MMA is the
sport of future it is undeniably more
entertaining is done undeniably more
digestible for the average fan so it's
it's easier five twenty five five minute
rounds so it's 25 minutes you know what
it is it a boxing match is only thirty
yes yeah you know I mean maybe a little
bit longer thirty or thirty six minutes
or whatever again it's not but the the
thing with boxing is you kind of need a
this is not like an intelligence thing
like you don't need a higher IQ but it's
the same thing with baseball like people
who watch baseball understand understand
the game they understand like the
pitching strategy they understand all
these other little nuances of baseball
so they can really appreciate it
the average fan that just comes in to
watch baseball they're like I don't get
it bros guys are striking out all the
time they're just either they eating
like what's happening it's on base three
out of ten times I'm just be impressed
yeah like this is this not good right
same thing with soccer like a lot of
people watch soccer like where's the
action bro like what's going on right um
we grew up watching boxing so I think
we're grandfathered into it but the
future generations like you can you can
not know anything about MMA and fall in
[ __ ] love with the absolute carnage
that exists within it now it's possible
that it gets more boring like boxing as
the athletes get better at the sport you
know when you reach the top of anything
it's very hard for it to be exciting
because everything you do I don't know
how to counter and everything I do you
know how to counter so there's a version
of a stalemate
but right now I'm amazed in a pretty
rough space still where like they're
random guys that aren't that technical
they're just massively talented like
this guy Francis in Ghana
he's this guy from Cameroon I believe he
is massive 6-4 260 pounds solid [ __ ]
rock and he went up against his other
guy named gyre Zeno Rosen strike or
something like that the guy calls him
out Jerez Ino Rosen strike calls him
I want to fight this guy and he said I
can't believe anybody would call me out
20 seconds knocks him out in 20 seconds
he just go straight at him yeah he just
runs straight on throws his big looping
right hand Terezin who catched him with
a hook it doesn't even phase him knocks
him his head completely unconscious
punches him a couple more times fights
over go home I mean unbelief I wear
these two guys are just tagging off in
each other's faces that both of them
look like clowns afterwards I mean eyes
puffy completely swollen dripping blood
all over the place the main that the the
main card just engage versus Tony
Ferguson Tony Ferguson is destroyed by
the end of this fight like his face
looks like a saw mask remember that yeah
yeah that's what he looked like it was
unbelievable I mean any is so much art
he's just going in there's getting
cracked by the Chi gate to the entire
time
impossible it's not like this it's
impossible and I like the sport right I
mean it was just like I'm seeing what
fight I'm seeing what fights Wars will
be in the future and there's no way it
can't be this and you know what makes it
so great hmm the tyranny of it democracy
in a lot of ways killed boxing how so
too many belts too many so because there
is merit in who fights who in boxing
right we've had to create more belts
when there was just one bell per
division you know what can happen a
really boring guy gets the belt mm-hm
and that guy maintains the Bell forever
and it's boring because his style sucks
yeah right the beauty of MMA is two
people you don't even know can fight
each other and it can be the most
exciting fight in the world because it's
a closest thing to a street fight or a
bar fight and we'll watch those all day
right right so what they do the UFC is
one organization so they control all the
matchmaking etc they decide who fight
too they say you're the second ranked
contender but if they don't want you to
fire them you don't fight them you can't
sue yeah in boxing you have these
multiple organizations and you're
fighting for belts in each one and
they're the organizations are competing
against each other and switching
rankings and that kind of stuff you kind
of like
I off if you want to fight someone else
instead there's a little bit more merit
in it the fact that there's a one guy in
the MMA or in the UFC specifically going
you're fighting this guy can create
these amazing fights because that one
guy can go all those Styles aren't gonna
match up don't let them fight it'll be
boring mm-hmm and then you create a
figure like cowboy Cerrone have you
heard of the you know Cowboys running
out of him cowboy Cerrone in boxing
would be like a journeyman boxer who
like never really amounted to much but
would fight a couple fights and then
he'd be out of there he became a
superstar in MMA because they matched
him perfectly with guys around his
talent level hmm and then every once a
while when he jumps up to like the elite
elite he gets his ass kicked this is one
McGregor beat the [ __ ] out of him yes
and like loved him like was actually
gracious and nice and yeah but that's
what happens that guy's such a great
character and makes amazing fights no
matter who he's with so what you do is
you make him fight guys that are around
his level that he can beat yeah and then
you take this character and you make him
this like almost folk hero within MMA
but you never really expose him to the
craziest [ __ ] right and then you do when
he can make a lot of money hey you've
done a lot of good work for the business
you're gonna fight McGregor you're gonna
make your big paycheck and you could do
this with a bunch of little fighters
right and have them have these really
exciting fights and build them up on
like boxing where it's like okay you
kind of gotta fight this guy cuz he's
your mandatory challenger and yada yada
yada yeah I think it's brilliant man do
you think it was like so good because
you haven't seen live sports and I think
there's part of it I think it's
definitely part of it I think I was
craving something that was just
happening in the moment I'll be honest I
didn't even well I didn't bother me at
all that nobody was in there I really
liked it like did you listen to it you
watch a fight and I didn't really
affected that much it was a little weird
the beginning but by the end I didn't
notice do I think it improved it because
sometimes the audience whoo's and oohs
and ahhs at punches that don't really
connect and it throws you off in it
maybe can throw the judges off but when
there's just a few guys in there like
literally the fighters could hear their
coaches coaching them mmm and you could
hear the fighters talk to their coaches
yeah right you
here rogon and uh Cormier and the other
guy talking during the fight at one
point they all go oh [ __ ] I think the
fighters can hear us we should lower our
voices crazy is there being critical of
a guy who's actually in the ring punch
did ya see what's funny it's like I
usually like the excitement of the crowd
because then usually Rogen has to like
yell oh wait a minute adds to that
excitement yet he's yelling and he just
has that energy yeah oh [ __ ] he's
hypoxic oh it's like I guess if I
thought it would take away a little bit
from the thing but when you get in there
it's really kind of nice and like you
get kind of locked in and quiet like I
don't know like I'm sure when you've had
fights whenever you have a fight you
can't hear anything
don't yeah anybody ever had like even
when I would spark sound didn't exist
yeah it's so weird and that's kinda what
happens in the fight nobody's there I
don't get me wrong it's fun to go to
fights I can't wait till people get back
but it didn't take away from the
experience that bad mmm I've been able
to hear the corners was really it was
cool yeah it really adds something Tony
Ferguson his corner had some of the
worst advice I've ever heard in my
entire life like at one point the guy
goes breathe Tony actually no that's not
bad advice
sorry not bad advice on something
because you know you box as well this
times where it's like you're just
throwing throwing throwing throwing
throwing and then you gas yourself out
not realizing but it's like if you were
breathing that whole time
you can keep going at this level you
breathe when you punch and you breathe
when you kick this is the elite of the
elite right it's like you don't have you
tell that to somebody at their first day
a boxing class where you go don't hold
your breath when you throw your punches
actually exhale matter of fact if
anybody's listening right now and you
hear a lot of times when people punch
you hear them go huh so that's just a
like Pavlovian response to throwing a
punch to remind yourself to breathe but
the in like yo I love Eddie Bravo I
think this guy's like a great character
but it seemed like Tony was not paying
attention to his corner at all like it
really seemed like like Eddie at one
point was like you might want to try one
of these roles called like a something
human re-roll it's basically lumen re
lumen re-roll and he like suddenly
suggested it I got a feeling you can't
tell Tony Ferguson what to do I got a
feeling
like his camp is just a little similar
to like Ali's camp where it's like
you'll tell Ali what to do Ali comes
with the idea and then you help him
execute it Howley's I'll either 100
percent you know I mean Tony Ferguson
hadn't lost since 2012 like he was a he
was an elite elite fighter he's just
coming up against this guy Justin Goethe
who I knew he was gonna lose to I was
texting Brennan Shaw about his Styles no
match every time I saw Tony Ferguson
fight he had no defense for hands
unbelievable athlete unbelievable
stamina unbelievable courage had [ __ ]
heart and very hard puncher he could
punch hard but he had no head movement
no defense for him so he would get
caught all the time this guy's just
engage he throws bombs yeah it's
dangerous he's a dangerous [ __ ] guy
to be in the ring with and if you have
no defense he's gonna tag you up he is
the perfect guy to beat Tony Ferguson
and you know what sucks Tony Ferguson I
think had the best chance of beating
khabib and now he's never gonna get to
fight him stylistically yeah cuz Kebede
will take you to the ground and Tony
Ferguson has amazing jujitsu right so
I'm wanted khabib to take Tony the
ground and then maybe Tony be able to
pull some cool [ __ ] throw some elbows
cut him up now just engage he's gonna
fight khabib and I'm gonna fight what's
that it won't even be and it won't be a
fight you're an MMA fan yeah kind of
generally okay but it's just like khabib
is so amazing he's gonna take gate you
to the ground granted gay cheese you
know has a wrestling background he was
successful he was a an unseen double-a
all-american wrestlers like North Col WA
Colorado or some like that but khabib is
a generational talent with wrestling
he's gonna take him to the [ __ ]
ground it's gonna hold in there it's
gonna be a boring fight you know who
would be a fireworks of a fight
Conor verse Goethe and I hope they make
that four weren't they talking [ __ ]
Conor was going eight on Twitter and
gate to his firing bag right I don't
know if Katie's responded yet but you
just had the usually had the what's a go
Conor tweets okay yeah and but that
would be a [ __ ] barn burner
[Applause]